two weeks the same modeling also shows
that by very vigorously following these
guidelines we could save more than 1
million American lives think of that 1
million American lives our future is in
our own hands and the choices and
sacrifices we make will determine the
fate of this virus and really the fate
of our victory we will have a great
victory we have no other choice
every one of us has a role to play in
winning this war
every citizen family and business can
make the difference in stopping the
virus this is our shared patriotic duty
challenging times are ahead for the next
30 days and this is a very vital 30 days
we're sort of putting it all on the line
this 30-day is so important because we
have to get back but the more we
dedicate ourselves today the more
quickly we will emerge on the other side
of the crisis and that's the time we're
waiting for the more we commit ourselves
now the sooner we can win the fight and
return to our lives and there will be
great lives maybe better than ever today
we reached a historic milestone in our
war against the coronavirus over 1
million Americans have now been tested
more than any other country by far not
even close and tested accurately and I
think what I'd like to do is ask
secretary a czar who's done a fantastic
job to come up and just say a few words
about the fact that we reached
substantially now more than 1 million
tests please thank you Alex
well thank you mr. president for your
leadership in marshaling all the
resources that we have for this
unprecedented testing effort and Thank
You mr. vice president for leading a
whole of economy approach to testing as
the president mentioned today the United
States hit more than 1 million samples
tested a number that no other country
has reached we're now testing nearly
100,000 samples a day
also a level that no other country has
reached I want to thank every partner
that has been involved in this effort
that includes all of the men and women
of the FDA and the CDC including
director Redfield and commissioner Han
together the FDA and CDC of work to
balance the need for testing on an
aggressive scale with the scientific
rigor that Americans expect working with
our testing coordinator Admiral Scheer
WA they have now truly unleashed the
ingenuity of the private sector and our
state and local leaders the centerpieces
of America's historic approach to
testing I want to thank those state and
local leaders who have used their
on-the-ground resources and knowledge to
lead testing and make it much more
easily accessible to the Americans who
need it I'm also grateful to FEMA with
whom we are now working closely to get
state and local partners what they need
I also want to thank CMS where
administrator Verma has given health
care providers unprecedented flexibility
to scale up capacity for testing and
treatment that has ensured that tests
will be paid for finally we would not be
where we are today without the many
American companies entrepreneurs and
scientists who have worked day and night
to develop as of today 20 different
emergency testing options with the FDA
responding to requests for authorization
tip typically within 24 hours the number
of options is growing nearly every day
FDA has also opened up new options for
using the available tests like self
swabbing and new options for reagents I
also want to thank FDA and other
components of HHS for incredibly rapid
action on other tools that we need this
weekend we actually work to secure 30
million tablets from Sandoz and 1
million tablets from Bayer of
hydroxychloroquine
and chloroquine which are potential
kovat 19 treatments and we authorized
Patel's new decamp decontamination
machines which can each sterilize
thousands of essential and 95 maps for
reuse every day so thank you mr.
president for your leadership and thank
you to everybody who's played a part in
getting us where we are today thank you
thank you
I'd like to ask dr. Hahn to come up FTA
because we have some really good stuff
first of all the numbers have been
incredible on testing but in the days
ahead we're going to go even faster and
we have something from Abbott Labs which
is right here and that's a five-minute
test highly accurate and I maybe can
show that as we listen to our FDA
Commissioner the job he's done and the
approval process we talked about the
cleric win and the hydroxychloroquine
just now I thought that I'd mentioned it
but alex has already done that but we
have that now under tests with 1,100
people in New York and it was only the
fast approval by FDA that allowed us to
do that it was a really rapid approval
and doctor please say a few words and
this is the first one on the line of the
five-minute test from Abbott Thank You
mr. president for your leadership Thank
You mr. vice president for your
leadership of the task force I'm very
proud of FDA staffs work in the last few
months to expedite the availability of
testing in this country I'm also
incredibly appreciative of private
industries ingenuity and willingness to
work with us quickly to develop and
distribute those tests we've had a
substantial addition to testing with the
authorization of point-of-care tests
especially the Abbott point of care test
which the president has pulled out of
the box a point-of-care test is a test
that gives you a result where you're
getting care this is truly a
patient-centered approach whether it's
the doctor's office a hospital and
emergency room at urgent care center or
a drive-by testing site
just like tests for flu or strep we go
to the doctor so you get the test done
you can get an answer within minutes of
having this test done now with those
tests being approved for Abbott and for
others these are available around the
country they're planning to scale up the
number of tests that can be put out
throughout the country over the next
month and patients can get the answer
within as little as 15 to 5 minutes and
then of course an appropriate plan of
treatment can be given
we at FDA are working quickly with
Abbott as well and other testing
approaches and normally these tests take
months to develop I was on the phone
today with the added CEO he told me that
normally this is a 9 to 12 month
approach to developing a point-of-care
test they did this in collaboration with
FDA and US government within weeks
Abbott has shared that they will be
delivering these tests tomorrow and then
will be ramping up just to emphasize one
thing the most innovative and safe
products come from the private sector in
partnership with government taking in
all hands on deck approach just like in
this case and the other point here is
that Abbott and FDA work together to
make sure that we had a fast reliable
and accurate test to market thank you
really great job thank you Steve so the
pharmaceutical company San does has been
working with us very closely and as Alex
mentioned a little bit 30 million doses
of the hydroxychloroquine to the United
States government it's been given and
bear has donated 1 million doses of the
chloroquine which will soon be
distributed to States and state health
officials around the country terentieva
Pharmaceuticals is also donating 6
million doses of hydroxychloroquine to
US hospitals 6 million doses so the
private sector as you'd say Steve it's
been amazing what's happened really
amazing and we're going to introduce you
to some of the greatest business
executives in the world today no matter
where you go and they're going to say a
little bit about what they're doing and
then we have so many more the FDA is
also authorized the Patels n95
respirator mask sterilization kits it's
an incredible thing I've been asking why
are we throwing these masks away you
look at some of these masks and they're
significant pieces of equipment and I
say how come you throw them away why
aren't they using sterilization
techniques and I got a call from Mike
DeWine the governor of Ohio and he's a
tremendous guy tremendous governor and
he said we have a company named batil
and they're having a hard time getting
approval from the FDA and I called up
dr. Hahn and within a very short period
of time they got the approval Steve we
really appreciate it I want to thank
Mike and I want to thank Steve and
they're going to be able each machine
now can disinfect 120,000 masks per day
now think of that each machine can
disinfect 120,000 masks per day it'll be
just like a new one it could go up to
about 20 times
for each mask so each mask can go
through this process 20 times and they
have to in Ohio one in New York and one
will soon be shipped to Seattle
Washington and also to Washington DC so
that's going to make a tremendous
difference on the masks this morning I
spoke to our nation's governor's to help
each state get the medical supplies they
need and yesterday Vice President Mike
Pence asked our nation's hospitals to
begin reporting total bed capacity ICU
bed capacity ventilator capacity and
vital medical supply levels on a daily
basis and Mike thank you for the great
job thank you very much in New York the
two thousand nine hundred bed hospital
under construction which is now
completed they completed it in three
days you might say three and a half days
at the Javits Center will be completed
today will be and when you look so
they're going up I think we're going to
be adding some more beds which will be
completed today and we've opened up what
to say goes our box and my hairs blow it
around and it's mine the one thing you
can't get away with if it's not usually
got a problem if your precedent and
nearly three thousand medical beds will
become operational the US Navy ship
comfort also arrived today equipped with
12 operating rooms and 1,000 hospital
beds work has begun or an additional
temporary hospital sites including a 600
bed capacity nursing home facility in
Brooklyn and numerous floors of a
high-rise building on Wall Street so
it's been really pretty amazing what
they've done the Army Corps of Engineers
what they've done they've done they they
just completed think of an a 2,900 bed
hospital in New York in just about three
days maybe four days and the whole city
is talking about it on top of that we
floated in a great ship which is going
to be a thousand rooms which is being
used for
patience outside of what we're focused
on and that will free up a lot of rooms
for what we're focused on so it's been
great the Army Corps of Engineers has
awarded contracts for the construction
of alternate care facilities also at the
State University at Stony Brook State
University Old Westbury and the
Westchester Community Center were
sending 60 ambulances to New York City
today we have a total of 60 we're
getting some additional ones with up to
190 more to follow at different
locations to date
FEMA has obligated more than 1.3 million
dollars billion dollars in federal
support to the state of New York so
we're spending a lot of money in New
York it's a hot it's a hot bed there's
no question about it
and we're spending a lot of time effort
on New York New Jersey spoke with
Governor Cuomo a lot spoke with Governor
Murphy a lot in New Jersey and we're
we're really getting the job done people
are very impressed and I'm very
impressed by the people and FEMA the
people in the Army Corps of Engineers
because what they've done I've never
seen anybody do anything like it in
addition to the 8,100 ventilators that
we've already delivered over the next 48
hours we're delivering more than 1,000
we're going 400 ventilators are going to
Michigan very shortly 300 going to New
Jersey 150 ventilators to Illinois 150
to Louisiana and 50 to Connecticut FEMA
and HHS already delivered 11.6 million
n95 respirators 26 million surgical
masks 5.3 million face shields 4.4
million surgical gowns and 22 million
gloves and I don't know if you just saw
it just came over the wires that Ford
just announced just a little while ago
that they will produce along with
General Electric healthcare 50,000
ventilators and they're going to be
doing it in less than one
hundred days and top of that we have
other companies that are doing
ventilators including General Motors but
we have nine other companies doing
ventilators as we outpace what we need
we're going to be sending up to Italy
we're going to be sending them to France
we're going to be sending them to Spain
where they have tremendous problems and
other countries as we as we can but the
fact that we're doing so many so quickly
is a tribute to our great companies more
than 14-thousand National Guard members
have been activated and can help
supplement state and local efforts to
distribute personal protective equipment
where we're sending a lot we have plane
loads coming in we have 51 loads from
various locations all around the world
and they're landing we had our first big
cargo plane land this morning and we're
getting it from all over the world and
we're also sending things that we don't
need to other parts I just spoke to the
Prime Minister of Italy and we have
additional capacity we have additional
product that we don't need we're going
to be sending approximately a hundred
million dollars worth of of things of
surgical and medical and hospital things
to Italy and Giuseppe was very very
happy I will tell you that they having a
very hard time joining us this afternoon
our CEOs of the great American companies
that are fulfilling their patriotic duty
by producing or donating medical
equipment to help meet our most urgent
needs what they're doing is incredible
and these are great companies
Darius Dom Scheck of Honeywell you know
that and Darius has been somebody that
I've dealt with in the past and he's a
great leader of a great company
Deborah Waller of jockey International a
friend of mine Mike lyndale of my pillow
boy do you sell those pillows that's
unbelievable what you do David Taylor
Pratt
gamble and Greg Hayes of United
Technologies Corporation and I just want
to tell all of you that America is very
grateful to you and what you've done an
amazing job you've done and we thank you
very much
I'd like you to come up and say a couple
of words if you might about your
company's Mike come on up come on up
fellas please come on up you have to say
what you're doing because it's been okay
well my pillow is a u.s. vertically
integrated company which has been forced
to adjust to the changing business
environment as a result of a pandemic my
pill is uniquely positioned as a US
company that functions as a manufacturer
logistics management distribute and
direct to consumer given our current
business lines we experience the effects
of this pandemic firsthand but my pill
is done with the established and
internal Task Force which is monitoring
future needs of companies across the
country as a result of this pandemic and
given our position we've begun to
research and develop new protocols to
address the current and future needs of
US businesses across multiple sectors
how companies are going to prepare
themselves when they once again open up
in and changes to their current
operations in order to adjust to future
threats and pandemics my pill has
designated some of its call center to
help us companies navigate the many
issues that resulted from this pandemic
we've debt we've dedicated 75% of my
manufacturing to produce cotton facemask
up to time in three days I was up to
10,000 a day by Friday I want to be up
to 50,000 a day I'm proud to manufacture
our products in the United States and
I'm even more proud to be able to serve
our nation in this great time of need
Thank You mr. president for your call to
action when which has empowered
companies like my pillow to help our
nation win this invisible war now I
wrote something off the cup if I can
read it okay
God gave us grace on November 8 2016 to
change the course we were on God had
been taken out of our schools and lie
a nation had turned his back on God and
I encourage you use this time at home to
get to home to get back in the word read
our Bibles and spend time with our
families our president gave us so much
hope we're just a few short months ago
we had the best economy the lowest
unemployment and wages going up it was
amazing with our great president vice
president and this administration and
all the great people in this country
praying daily we will get through this
and get back to a place that's stronger
and safer than ever I did not know he
was gonna do that but he's a friend of
mine and I do appreciate it thank you
Mike very much please first of all mr.
president mr. vice president the entire
administration and all the agencies
thank you for your strong leadership
during this time of crisis it is noticed
and it's making a difference second of
all I'd like to say a big thank you to
all the health care workers out there
you're putting yourself in arms away
every day and you really respect what
you're doing and we couldn't be thankful
enough for it and I can tell you that
more helps under way we as Honeywell or
an industrial technology company and one
of the businesses that were in and
protect the industrial worker well what
we're doing today is we're repurposing a
lot of that equipment to serve the
healthcare worker a few days ago we
announced the startup of a new
manufacturing facility in Rhode Island
we're going to be hiring 500 employees
we have already 200 on board and we're
going to be starting the production of
n95 masks within the next two weeks
furthermore today we're announcing the
start up of another manufacturing
facility in Arizona we're gonna be
hiring another 500 people and we're
going to be starting up production in
that facility by the middle of May so in
total we've doubled our production of
n95 masks already it's going to double
again within the next 60 days and then
within the next 90 days one of the 5x2
capacity we do today
furthermore we're going to providing
other safety equipment to support all
the efforts going on
lastly I'd say a big thank you to all
the Honeywell employees and also
announce a 10 million dollar fund for
them for all the hourly and
administrative employees are having a
hard time during this time of crisis
Thank You mr. president
Thank You mr. president and mr. vice
president on your guidance during this
unprecedented time and I'm very honored
to be here today
founded by a minister 144 years ago
Jokke International is a family-owned
company headquartered in Kenosha
Wisconsin since 1876 we have been
providing socks and underwear for
generations of families it is part of
our DNA to roll up our sleeves and help
our country in her time of need during
World War two we made parachutes for the
military and today we are eager to serve
this great country by providing support
for the health care workers on the
frontlines of this fight as the
president and vice president have said
it's a whole of America approach and we
are committed Jackie has had a
long-standing partnership with encompass
Group headquartered in Georgia serving
the health care community when we
learned of the critical need for PPE we
knew we had to help that meant
restarting production on tier three
isolation gowns monumental lifting by
Jackie encompass FEMA and the FDA was
done in just a few days to be
production-ready
as a result we expect to begin
delivering 30 to 50,000 gowns per week
helping those that need it the most
right now in addition this week we are
also donating ten thousand units of
scrubs to the frontline doctors and
nurses at the Javits Convention Center
in New York City we would not have been
able to do this without the
collaboration of the administration
representatives from the federal
agencies and congressman brian stiles
thank you very much mr. president and
mr. Vyse mr. vice president
Thank You mr. president mr. vice
president for bringing us together today
I'm proud to be able to represent the
men and women of Procter & Gamble who
every day 24 hours a day are working to
build and make essential cleaning
products hygiene products and health
care products for families everywhere
these include healthcare workers and for
institutions that are serving those in
the frontline P&G people are the faces
that brands you know and trust
brands like Tide Pampers bounty Charmin
mr. clean and Vicks in addition to
making packing and shipping these
essential items they've worked together
to transform our plants to make things
we've never made before like hand
sanitizers and facial masks some of
these are already getting to national
state and local agencies some of them
are in the hospitals already everywhere
around the world P&G people working
every day to serve everybody consumers
and they're working together to bring
together the full capability of our
research and development and our
engineering or manufacturing you know
communications capability to make sure
we make a difference to the consumers we
serve into all the audience that we can
make a difference to I want to thank
them and are very grateful for what they
do every day in service to others Thank
You mr. president mr. vice president for
brings together today
good afternoon I'm Greg Hayes from
United Technologies and on behalf of the
240,000 employees of United Technologies
and the 70,000 employees at Raytheon
which will join together with UTC this
Friday on a first of all say thank you
to the president and the vice president
for your leadership during what is
really a war it is a different war than
anybody has ever fought before but it's
a war that were uniquely qualified to
help there's one of the world's largest
defense contractors and some of the best
technology we're using that technology
to try and solve some real world
problems today we're working with the
Air Force to try and help pilots as
they're moving medical evacuated the
kovat 19 virus such that they can be
protected and that the patients can be
protected again we're working also with
logistics and if you think about a war
strategy is important but logistics wins
war and so it's imperative I think with
FEMA along with the the mr. Navarro's
office that we coordinate all of these
activities last week we donated about
90,000 pieces of personal protective
equipment to FEMA next week we'll have
another almost million again working
through our supply chain partners of
around the world
we're also today this week beginning the
manufacturer of face shields using the
additive technologies that we have and
the machines that we have available
within the UTC will be able to produce
approximately 10,000 shields in the next
four weeks again all needed equipment we
stand ready to help in any way we can we
don't need the defense production act to
ask us to act all of the people are UTC
and Raytheon
are focused on this war and winning it
again I also want to say thank you to
all of our employees for their work
during this crisis as well as to the
frontline medical and other first
responders thank you very much
those are great companies thank you very
much I'd like to ask Seema to come up
and say a few words about what you're
doing and what's happening and how
positive it's been I really appreciate
it come on up Seema Verma
Thank You mr. president and let me start
by saying I want to convey my deepest
sympathies to those that have lost loved
ones to the coronavirus we're all
thinking of you today is doctor's day
and even without it I want to send a
message of gratitude to the foot
soldiers in this war men and women that
are providing care and comfort to
Americans that have been affected by the
virus your country is grateful and in
short as the president has said we are
engaged in a war against an invisible
enemy in wartime the assumptions of
peacetime must be revisited and adjusted
to meet the demands of the moment and so
under the president's leadership CMS is
waiving a wide an unprecedented range of
regulatory requirements now many health
care systems won't need these waivers
and they shouldn't use them if they
don't need them but the flexibilities
are there in a time of crisis
regulations shouldn't stand in the way
of patient care and there are several
components to our announcement today but
the first one is CMS's hospitals without
walls and this is going to allow
hospital systems to create new treatment
sites outside of their facility to
expand capacity and be able to safely
separate patients that are infected with
the corona virus and those that are not
now FEMA is doing incredible work
setting up temporary hospitals and in
York and other areas but under these
waivers we are empowering local
communities to complement and augment
the work of FEMA and allowing hospital
systems to tap into the capacity that
already exists in their communities
making use of dorms and hotels or
gymnasiums and allowing the main
Hospital to focus on those that need the
most intensive care there are surgery
centers out there today that are
delaying elective surgeries and they may
have excess
capacity that can be devoted to hospital
like care we are also making changes to
the Medicare program to facilitate
testing so some people that need a
coronavirus test can't leave their home
or patients that are in a nursing home
and now we will pay for labs to go out
to these locations and perform testing
and we're also expanding the workforce
we are taking action today to relax some
of our regulations to allow hospitals to
increase their workforce and we're
allowing a broad range of flexibilities
so that we can let healthcare workers
operate at the top of their license and
we are also allowing our hospitals to
give to provide more support for our
healthcare workers under today's
regulations they can only provide
minimal support to healthcare workers
but now we're going to allow them to
provide childcare meals laundry services
and then there's also telehealth the
president already directed a dramatic
expansion of telehealth to our nation's
62 million seniors with Medicare and
we're so proud of all the health care
health care providers and patients that
have rapidly implemented telehealth but
today we're announcing that we're going
to go even further and we're going to be
paying for doctors to make phone calls
with their patients and provide care
over the phone and we're getting rid of
long-standing barriers to telehealth in
the Medicare program allowing emergency
rooms to use telehealth and eliminating
requirements that some does it's be
provided face-to-face and I also want to
mention that on Saturday the president
directed CMS to offer advance payments
for healthcare providers that are
experiencing cash flow problems we know
that many providers are complying with
our recommendations to delay
non-essential elective surgeries and
they shouldn't be penalized for doing
the right thing now I've barely
scratched the surface of all the
flexibilities that we are offering
health care workers and health care
systems these flexibilities will provide
a lot of flexibility from regulations
that are ill-suited to the unprecedented
needs of this emergency and doctors and
nurse
and other healthcare professionals that
are working long hours and sacrificing
times with their families and risking
their lives will have the flexibility
that they need to confront the needs of
the corona virus pandemic and there are
many heroes in this war but I want to
take an opportunity to thank the team at
CMS these folks have worked day and
night the flexibilities that are in this
regulation and any regulation usually
takes CMS a year but we did this in two
weeks and I couldn't be more honored and
privileged to serve alongside these
dedicated public servants thank you and
you're doing a great job so we are in
the midst of something that is very
difficult but we are going to win it's
just a question of when we want to do it
as quickly as possible we want to have
as few deaths as possible and we will
meet again tomorrow for some statistics
and some updates as to where we are
where we think we're going and timing I
think timing is going to be very
important because we have to get our
country back we have to get our country
back to where it was it may be beyond
where it was because we've learned so
much but we will have lost a lot of
people and in many ways they're heroes
and if you look at what's happening with
our medical professionals it's a danger
there they're warriors men and women are
doing a job that the likes of which I
don't think anyone's ever seen I see
them coming out of planes today going
into New York going into the most
dangerous locations dangerous areas and
they go in there and they just want to
do the job and you see the numbers you
see the numbers like I see the numbers I
have some friends that are unbelievably
sick we thought they were going in for a
mild stay and in one case he's
unconscious in a coma and you say how
did that happen so I just want to thank
all of the great professionals men and
women doctors and nurses and
paramedics and first responders and law
enforcement by the way if you look at
New York and you see how the effect that
that's had in law enforcement it's been
incredible these are great people
firefighters great people they're
helping in so many different ways so
thank you very much and if you'd like
we'll take a few questions John please
mr. president
yesterday you said that you would be
extending the guidelines through the end
of April and that you'd be giving us
specifics tomorrow do you expect it the
guidelines will just carry on the
guidelines that have been in place now
for 15 days could there potentially be
some modification also you have some
travel restrictions that come up for
reconsideration the one from the EU on
April 13th Canada us-mexico border on
April the 21st well what will happen
with all these saying we may add a few
more but the guidelines would be very
much as they are maybe even toughened up
a little bit but they're having a big
impact they're having a tremendous
impact that we're starting to see it and
that's the key we're starting to see the
impact that they're having and if I
could ask you to you're talking about
Ford now ramping up production of
ventilators the government is sending
thousands of ventilators across the
country
clearly the supply is increasing but
when you look at the production curve
against the hospitalization curve can
you guarantee that everyone who needs a
ventilator in the next few weeks will be
able to get one well I think that some
are ramping up to a level that they're
not going to have to John and I think
that we also have kept in reserve we
have almost 10,000 ventilators in our
line we have them we've held back just
because we did the stockpile we didn't
want to give them because we don't know
where the emergency this hits it's like
so fast it comes so quickly
and we have 10,000 we're probably going
to send some of them now we've been
sending a lot to Michigan and various
other states will probably send some
additional ones to Michigan New York's
been doing very well but we can add some
more to New York we're adding them to
the areas that are having a problem even
Alabama all of a sudden flared up a
little bit as you saw over the last
couple of
and we'll send them down to Alabama so
we have 10,000 we kept them for this
very specific purpose it sounds like a
lot but it's not when you think about it
but we're making a lot and when you see
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands being made in a very short
period of time because if you look at
what just so we have now ten companies
at least making the ventilators and we
say go ahead because honestly other
countries really they'll never be able
to do it it's a very complex piece of
equipment and it's it's big and
expensive do you believe as we approach
this peak in a couple of weeks that
there will be enough for the American
Pie yes I do think so I think we're
gonna be in very good shape and we had a
great call today with the governors and
they were I actually said I hope that
the media is listening to this call
because it was a really good call and
that was randomly selected largely
Democrats and Republicans and they're I
think for the most part they were saying
thank you for doing a great job and we
discussed that at the end of the call so
really people are very happy with what
we're doing now the circumstances are so
terrible because of what's going on but
I think they're very impressed by the
federal government I watched that
beautiful ship floating in today into
you know weeks ahead of schedule almost
four weeks ahead of schedule
into New York Harbor comfort and I
watched the Mersey floating in to Los
Angeles a week ago almost a week ago and
they are stocked they are really ready
to go they're stocked with both talent
and tremendous amounts of equipment and
the Navy and everybody else involved
they got it ready so fast it's it's just
incredible what they can do they've
geared up that's why I mean I am so
impressed by the people involved Mike
and I were talking about it before the
level of genius to put it all together
so quickly
this wasn't a month ago nobody ever
heard of this nobody had any idea the
mercy was being maintained it was in
maintenance for a month
and when they heard we needed it and I
was surprised they said sir we're ready
to go I said what do you mean you're not
going to
ready for three weeks no sir we're all
ready to go it was incredible so and
we've had many instances like this I
think the building of the hospital 2900
beds in a matter of days a few days is
just incredible Governor Cuomo was
impressed and gavin newsom was impressed
by what we've been doing with gavin and
California and Los Angeles area in
particular but really San Francisco all
over all over California when you look
at what we're doing with Michigan we're
getting along very well with Michigan's
great great place we're sending a lot of
things to Michigan because that's
becoming a hotbed especially a specific
area as you know it's become very hot
it's become I don't know could even at
some point supersede but it's it's got
to be taken care of so we're the
relationship we have with the governor's
I just wish you could because we took a
lot of calls from a lot of different
states and I wish you could have heard
even a thing where like the Governor of
Ohio calls where he has a company that
does the sterilization but they have a
problem because it's not going quickly
at the FDA and I call up Steve and Steve
comes it mmm he said we'll get it done
and they checked it and they got it done
almost immediately and originally they
were approving it for 10,000 masks and
then it was supposed to be for 80 and
they ultimately approved it for 120,000
it's a tremendous number and I kept
wondering why aren't they sterilizing
these minutes if I assume maybe you
couldn't do it but then I'd look at them
and they'd look like you know it's not
cloth it's something that looks like it
could be sterilized and that's what
they've done and that's the machine that
is over there actually they have a piece
of the machine over there I won't bother
showing it to you and this is incredible
when you talk about five minutes 15
minutes and highly accurate and not
nearly as disturbing to do as the other
test so we've just gotten better we're
doing things that nobody else ever
thought oh please
TFE has issued stamp orders that
governor route Northern Virginia took it
pretty far he issued a 70 days
stay-at-home order
it's that constitutional first off and
secondly do you think it's warranted to
go ahead and issued a 70 day guidance at
this point
well we're letting the governors do in
their states pretty much what they want
with our supervision and they consult
with us in all cases some go further
than others as you know I mean I could
give you plenty of examples but I'm not
going to do that because we never want
to be controversial but some of the
governors have taken it a step further
and people are questioning people are
questioning that but look staying at
home with respect to what we're talking
about doesn't bother me at all people
should be staying at home that's what we
want
oay in five americans have died from
corona virus in the last 60 days yeah
meanwhile you have 2369 children who are
killed by their mothers through elective
abortions each day that's 16 and a half
thousand children killed every week two
states have suspended elective abortion
to make more resources available for
coronavirus cases that's Texas in Ohio
do you agree with States who are placing
coronavirus victims
above elective abortions and should more
states be doing the same well I think
what we're doing is we're trying to as a
group governor's and that's Republicans
and Democrats yet we're just working
together to solve this problem that's
been a what you're mentioning has been
going on for a long time and it's it's a
sad event a lot of sad events in this
country but what we're doing is now
we're working on the virus we're working
on that hidden enemy and I think we're
doing a great job on as good a job as
you could possibly do when when Tony and
Deborah came up with numbers yesterday
to say that if we did nothing you could
lose 2.2 up to two point and maybe
beyond that or maybe beyond but 2.2
million people if we did nothing and I
can't tell you what the unfortunate
final toll is going to be but it's going
to be over
small fraction of that so we're doing an
awfully good job I think with what we're
doing please go ahead are you
considering it all I nationwide stay at
home order I know there's a lot of
states that have put them in place but
some haven't I'm just wondering if you
were considering some sort of broad stay
at home owner and I have a question for
dr. Burks well we've talked about it we
obviously there are some parts of the of
the country that are in far deeper
trouble than others there are other
parts that frankly are not in trouble at
all so CLE hopefully we're going to be
able to keep it that way by doing what
we're doing so we talked about
quarantine as you know the other day a
group came to me and they wanted to do
the quarantine and I said let's think
about it and we did it we studied it and
by the time the evening came it just was
something that was very unwieldy very
tough to enforce and something we didn't
want to do but we did advisory and I
think that's doing well I mean I I see I
look at the streets you look at New York
where there's I look down Fifth Avenue
today they were showing a shot of Fifth
Avenue and sort of primetime and there
was almost nobody on Fifth Avenue I've
never seen that before there was no car
there was no anything so I think the
people of this country have done an
incredible job if we do that we will let
you know but it's pretty unlikely I
would think at this time okay it's a
quick question for dr. Bruce
so dr. Burks if you don't mind you had
mentioned today that this model that
predicts the hundred thousand deaths is
if we do things almost perfectly so I
wanted to know are we currently doing
things almost perfectly or are there
more things we need to be doing to cap
you know to not exceed that hundred
thousand two hundred thousand model
thank you I think that's a really great
question and tomorrow we'll go through
all of the graphs and all the
information that we took to the
president for the decision but when you
and I just want to thank the data team
that's working day and night to get I
mean I usually get my data about 2:00
a.m. from them and they assimilate all
the data from all the states and when
you look at all of the states together
all of them are moving in exactly the
same curves and so that's why we really
believe this needs to be federal
guidance so that every state understands
that it may look like two cases today
that become 20 that become 200 that
become 2,000 and that's what we're
trying to prevent
and I think states still have that
opportunity but they're going to have to
do all of these recommended I mean these
recommendations are recommendations that
the globe is using and so we really do
recommend that every governor every
mayor looks very carefully and ensures
that their communities are utilizing
these guidance it is amazing you look at
Louisiana and for a long time it was
just it was just staying and nothing and
then all of a sudden I look one day and
I see a lot and a lot and a lot and then
it explodes and now we're working very
carefully and very powerfully with them
we're building hospitals who were
building a lot of different things for
Louisiana so it's very important yeah
please go ahead this could be seasonal
seasonal cyclical virus so and maybe
both of you could comment on this and
dr. Burks as well are you prepared for
this to strike again say in the fall all
the efforts that are taking place right
now to contain this to be proactive and
I hope it doesn't happen doctor would
you like to say something about that I
hope it doesn't happen but we're
certainly prepared in fact I would
anticipate that that would actually
happen because of the degree of
transmissibility however if you come
back in the fall it will be a totally
different ballgame
of
happened when we first got hit with it
in the beginning of this year there will
be several things that will be different
our ability to go out and be able to
test identify isolate and contact trace
will be orders of magnitude better than
what it was just a couple of months ago
in addition we have a number of clinical
trials that are looking at a variety of
therapeutic interventions we hope one or
more of them will be available and
importantly as I mentioned to you many
times at these briefings is that we have
a vaccine that's on track and multiple
other candidates so I would anticipate
that you know a year to a
year-and-a-half we'd be able to do it on
there an emergency use if we start
seeing an efficacy signal we may be able
to even use a vaccine at the next season
so things are going to be very very
different what we're going through now
is going to be more than just lessons
learned it's going to be things that we
have available to us that we did not
have before Scott
thank you Scott Gottlieb your former FDA
Commissioner wrote a roadmap for
recovery after the corona virus he
suggests that the the roadmap suggest
that everybody wear a mask in public is
that something that the task force
thinks it's a good idea I haven't
discussed it to that extent but it's
certainly something we could discuss
we're getting certainly the number of
masks that you need we are in the
process of talking about things I saw
his suggestion on that so we'll take a
look at it for a period of time not
forever I mean you know we want our
country back we're not going to be
wearing masks forever but it could be
for a short period of time after we get
back into gear people could I could see
something like that happening for a
period of time but I would hope it would
be a very limited period of time doctors
they'll come back and say for the rest
of our lives we have to wear masks the
road map also talks about doing GPS for
a social distancing maybe follow up
following people's phones and hotels for
isolation for people giving them free
hotel rooms are those ideas that you're
looking at well the GPS that's a very
severe idea
I've been hearing about it GPS so what
happens a siren goes off if you get too
close to somebody that's pretty severe
but he's somebody he was with me for a
long time he worked they did a great job
at FDA so so we're gonna take a look I
just I just received it a little while
ago he sent it over so very good
go ahead let's give it a shot what do
you say to Americans who are upset with
you over the way you downplayed this
crisis over the last couple of months we
have it very much under control in this
country the corona virus is very much
under control in the USA it's going to
disappear it's like a miracle it will
disappear March fourth we have a very
small number of people in this country
infected March 10th we're prepared we're
doing a great job with it it will go
away just a calm it will go away what do
you say to Americans will be that you
got this wrong and I do want them to
stay calm and we are doing a great job
if you look at those individual
statements they're all true stay calm it
will go away you know it you know it is
going away and it will go away and we're
gonna have a great victory and it's
people like you and CNN that say things
like that that it's why people just
don't want to listen to CN anymore you
could ask a normal question the
statements I made or I want to keep the
country calm I don't want panic in the
country I could cause panic much better
than even you I could do much I would
make you look like a minor league player
but you know what I don't want to do
that I want to have our country be calm
and strong and fight and win and it will
go away and it is incredible the job
that all of these people are doing
putting them all together the job that
they're doing I am very proud of the job
they're doing that Mike Pence is doing
that the task force has done that
Honeywell and Proctor and Gamble and
Mike and all of these people have done
I'm very proud it's it's almost a
miracle and it is the way it's all come
together and instead of asking a nasty
snarky question like that you should ask
a real question and other than that I'm
going to go to somebody else please go
ahead please
earn you express some concern in the
past that medical supplies were going
out the back door and that perhaps some
hospitals were doing things were dressed
what was told to me by a tremendous
power in the business he said that at a
New York Hospital for a long period of
time he was giving ten thousand maybe
maximum twenty thousand masks over a
short time and all of a sudden he's
giving three hundred thousand and I said
no matter how bad this is could that be
possible he said no so there's only a
couple of things that could happen is it
going out the back door and I've
reported it to the city and let the city
take a look at it but when you go from
ten thousand masks to three hundred
thousand masks Mike over the same period
of time there's something going on now
I'm not making any charges but when
everyone's looking for masks and by the
way that's another thing we're making a
lot of masks and the sterilization
process is going to save a lot of time
and a lot of masks but when when you
have the biggest distributor of product
that distributes to many of the big
hospitals and hospital chains and he
brings up a statistic like that and I
know you're trying to make a big deal
out of it but you shouldn't be you
should actually go over to the hospital
and find out why you shouldn't be asking
me I'm just saying that's the way it is
you should go over there as a great
reporter I have no idea who you are but
that's okay you should go over there go
to the hospital and find out how come
you used to get ten thousand masks and
you had a full Hospital New York City
always fall and how come now you have
three hundred thousand masks
despite the virus at all you have three
how do you go from ten to 300,000 and
this is very serious stuff I mean I
could see from ten to twenty or from ten
to forty or fifty or something but how
do you go from ten to 300,000 masks so
what I think you should do is a I'm sure
you're a wonderful investigative
reporter you should go to the hospital
and find out what okay yeah Steve please
well it's it's so bad for the economy
but the economy is number 2 on my list
first I want to save a lot of lives
we're gonna get the economy back I think
the economy is going to come back very
fast Steve's just asking about the
economy what's it like
we basically shut down our country and
we did that in order to keep people
separated keep people apart they're not
working in offices they're not in
airplanes together you know we really
shut it down
and you know 150 151 other countries
they're pretty much shut down but here
were they we had the greatest economy in
the world we had the greatest economy in
the history of our country and I had to
go from doing a great job for three
years to shutting it down but you know
what we're gonna build it up and we're
gonna build it up rapidly and I think in
the end we'll be stronger for it we
learned a lot we learned a lot and I
have to say we've had great
relationships with a lot of countries
China sent us some stuff which was
terrific Russia sent us a very very
large plane load of things medical
equipment which was very nice
other countries sent us things that I
was very surprised that very happily
surprised we learned a lot we're
learning a lot and we're also learning
that the concept of borders is very
important to Steve it's very important
having borders is very very important
but we have done an incredible job the
economy is going to come back my focus
is saving lives that's the only focus I
can have we're gonna bring the economy
back and we'll bring it back fast yeah
please please thank you miss Thank You
mr. president you said several times
that the United States has ramped up
testing to talk a little quicker a
little louder
mr. president you said several times
that the United States has ramped up
testing but the United States is still
not testing per capita as many as many
people as other countries like South
Korea why is that and when do you think
that that number will be on par with
other countries it's very much fun part
the look look per capita we have areas
of country
that's very wait I know South Korea
better than anybody it's a very tight
you know how many people are in sold you
getting out big the city of Seoul is 38
million people that's bigger than
anything we have 38 million people all
tightly wound together we have vast
farmlands we have vast areas where they
don't have much of a problem in some
cases they have no problem whatsoever we
have done more tests what I didn't I
didn't talk about per capita we have
done more tests by far than any country
in the world by far our testing is also
better than any country in the world and
when you look at that as simple as that
looks that's something that's a
game-changer and every country wants
that every country so rather than asking
a question like that you should
congratulate the people that have done
this testing because we inherited this
administration inherited a broken system
a system that was obsolete a system that
didn't work it was okay for a tiny small
group of people but once you got beyond
that it didn't work we have built an
incredible system to the fact what we
have now done more tests than any other
country in the world and now the
technology is really booming I just
spoke to well I spoke to a lot I'm not
going to even mention I spoke to a
number of different testing companies
today and the job that they've done and
the job that they're doing is incredible
but when Abbott comes out and does this
so quickly it's really unreal
in fact one company I have to say that
stands out in the job and I think I can
say this I don't want to insult anybody
else but Roach Roach has been incredible
in the testing job they've done and
they're ramping it up exponentially it's
up up up up and you should be saying
congratulations on instead of asking a
really snarky question because I know
exactly what you mean by that you should
be saying congratulations to the men and
women who have done this job who have
inherited a broken testing system and
who have made it great and if you don't
say it I'll say it I want to
congratulate all of the people you have
done a fantastic job and we will see you
all tomorrow thank you very much